- GOOD MORNING,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
WE ARE ABOUT
TO BEGIN BOARDING
SOUTH NORTHERN AIRLINES
FLIGHT 34 TO GRAND RAPIDS.
- OH, OKAY, I'M--EXCUSE ME.
BOARDING GROUP ONE.
I'M IN BOARDING GROUP ONE.
EXCUSE ME.
- AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN PRE-BOARDING
WITH OUR FIRST-CLASS
PASSENGERS.
FIRST-CLASS PASSENGERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
NEXT, OUR BUSINESS-CLASS
PASSENGERS MAY NOW BOARD.
OKAY, NOW
WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME
OUR REGAL ALLIANCE
ELITE MEMBERS.
REGAL ALLIANCE ELITE
MEMBERS.
OKAY, NOW ALL PASSENGERS
WITH CHILDREN.
- OKAY.
- ANYONE WITH SMALL CHILDREN
MAY BOARD NOW.
[child fussing]
- OKAY, WE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE BOARDING
WITH UNIFORMED
MILITARY PERSONNEL.
- WHAT?
WHY CAN'T--
THIS IS--
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SERVICE.
GOD BLESS YOU.
- THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
ALL RIGHT,
PEOPLE IN WHEELCHAIRS.
ANY PRIESTS, NUNS,
RABBIS, IMAMS.
- WHAT? WHY DO THEY
GET SPECIAL TREATMENT?
- AS-SALAAM-ALAIKUM.
- I'VE NEVER--
THAT'S TYPICAL.
- ANY OLD PEOPLE IN WHEELCHAIRS
WITH BABIES?
[baby cries]
- DOESN'T SEEM
PARTICULARLY--
- ANY OLD, RELIGIOUS PEOPLE
WITH MILITARY BABIES?
- WHAT'S A MILITARY--
- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE.
JASON SCHWARTZMAN.
ANYONE WITH A BLUE SUITCASE,
YOU MAY NOW BOARD.
- FINALLY.
- NOPE, NOT YOU, SIR.
- NOT ME?
THIS IS A BLUE SUITCASE.
- THAT'S A BLUE COMPUTER BAG.
- SO YOU'RE NOT--
YOU'RE NOT GONNA LET ME ON THEN?
- [sips loudly]
- DAMN IT!
DAMN IT, DAMN IT, DAMN IT,
DAMN IT, DAMN IT!
GOD DAMN IT!
- ANYONE WHO DOESN'T
SEEM CRANKY.
DRUNK PEOPLE.
WE WILL NOW BE BOARDING
ANY DRUNK PEOPLE.
DRUNK PEOPLE.
- [grunts]
ALL RIGHT, IT'S--
NOPE, IT'S MY BAG.
SIR. JUST--
[groans]
[indistinct muttering]
[phone rings]
- OOH.
HELLO?
OH, HEY, CHRISTIAN.
YEAH.
TOTALLY.
WELL, YOU HAVE YOUR FAVORITES,
AND I HAVE MY FAVORITES.
[laughs]
OKAY.
CALL YOU LATER.
CIAO, CIAO.
BOARDING GROUP ONE.
[dramatic music]
[sirens wailing]
[indistinct chatter]
♪ ♪
- AND THE FUSELAGE.
- I FOUND
JASON SCHWARTZMAN!
ALL RIGHT,
THAT'S EVERYBODY!
LET'S WRAP IT UP, PEOPLE.
- [groans]
BOARDING GROUP ONE
OVER HERE!
GOT A BOARDING GROUP ONE.
[groans]